[Applause]
I'm gonna start by just introducing each
of our nominees on the far end we have
an Morgan from bombshell Niki Lederman
Joker Trista miss louse from 1917 and
then buried our Tapio Salmi and Lizzie
Annie George from Rocket Man we'll talk
about each of the films individually I
just wanted to put the first question
out to all of you in terms of these
particular films when you first got the
script what was the first thing that
kind of spoke to you about each of the
film's we'll start at the end with an I
think that first the density of the
script of characters that were real-life
characters and knowing that people would
know certainly in the United States that
they would know who those characters
were so knowing that we would have to
clearly make people look similar or
something that people would understand
them and then to fold to that is the Fox
world is a world that I wasn't familiar
with it's not a news station that I tune
into per se but it is its own microcosm
of a world and and that was what I was
looking at like wow it's you know
mastering that that was my first
impression nickimja the Joker it was not
so much seeing the script it's to hear
from my producer who has hired me she
says oh yeah by the way it's gonna be
the Joker I think that to me it was like
oh my god how am I supposed to do a
Joker
there's been so many amazing Joker's it
was like terrifying and exciting at the
same time so that was really my initial
thought when hearing I'm gonna be doing
the Joker and I have to come up with a
new icon
look that I have no idea how I'm gonna
do that so that was pretty much you know
my first initial reaction to the movie
itself and then Tristan with 1970 I
think it from the script it was the
journey was the journey the characters
go through and the the intensity of
following those characters throughout
and the quantity of soldiers and
characters and everything that kind of
comes through that parcel on that
journey so I think it was trying to
figure out the quantity the detail
within that journey and how it was all
going to be placed so it all kind of
adds to the to the story I think we're
not as obviously after the Joseph one of
uh sort of hugest stars in the world so
that was really exciting but to actually
then see there's the space of time that
we would have to cover that you know had
to cover forty years and then to realize
that there's dance numbers as well on
top of that and those dance numbers
carrying you through to the next era so
that was all quite you know it was quite
sort of or inspiring but also daunting
to sort of trying to you know see how we
were going to actually change town from
a 17 year old dealt and right the way
through to a 40 year old
Elton and you know and also all the
people that go with him as well his
mother his his grandmother his
stepfather all those people had to age
with him as also as a massive task um in
terms of talking about the heavenly
change in kind of going from that
seventeen year old then through the
decades and then back-and-forth that
kind of obvious you're not filming the
same time period sometimes you know the
same day or even the next day how what
kind of what's your team look like for
that and how do you work too short so
for this of their little prosthetic
pieces for Tarrant and and the other
people in his family and Ernie as well
we sort of did tests and made sure that
we we weren't overloading
characters so we had to be very
considerate really because not only were
we having to age Terran and age these
other actors but we're also doing we
were trying to make them look like
somebody as well
so it was when we started off we
originally move we might been doing
quite extensive pieces on towns around
his face and getting closer to Elton but
it was just gonna be so extensive it we
never really work on a day-to-day basis
so it was really just consideration was
the only answer I mean which talent we
had done we had three people that were
with him most of the time especially
when the prosthetic was wrong because he
had a bald cap as well and a wig on top
of that and then little sideburn little
eyebrows like you know no no never label
liner we originally did make the old
gentleman showers as well but and the
reflection on one of the costumers was
troubling the cameraman so he had to
kind of drop that after the you know we
did shoot on it for a day and then we
had to subtly lose that but all those
were like you know that we had that hair
imprinted into them as well so they
would match his hairline because we let
him have a big more of a bid line there
to show him breaking down when he's
taking drugs and he's not feeling
himself so there was all these other
little trips that you did that help the
prosthetic salon so it wasn't a great
big it was there was there was
prosthetic but it was all the other
things that kind of went with it as well
so an image and aesthetic is so much in
what he is no unfortunate to be able to
show kind of the darker side of his life
through those things there as well yeah
exam very I thought was quite tearful
actually
moments one kid yeah I need love
it was very beginning of the film we
were shooting it and everybody was just
like in tears somewhat sad because it
was just so powerful it was speeding
song I suppose and moving on to another
little bit of Darkness with Joker in a
way for clowns don't know for Niki if
this is correct in my reading but a lots
of clown and look especially within the
film or have they been copyrighted you
know or think you know or it's out there
that you don't know
is copy written and it's funny that's
actually a cute little book that has
every clown design painted on a little
egg and that's sort of the registry of
the clown makeup looks that are
registered and of course we all had this
book to make sure like we can't do this
we came to this we can't even go near
this you know so that was a big
challenge to come up with something that
was not copy written I suppose what's so
different about this Joker is that it is
set in our world or in an actual world
to in that vein I'm not sure but does
the makeup have to then reflect someone
that it may be applying it more
themselves and more in a naturalistic
way and how did you work as opposed well
I came to kind of create you know a self
applied look that is obviously very
stylish at the same time well it was
very important that the makeup look is
not like the perfect precise clown
makeup the makeup needed to look
imperfect and needed to look that pretty
much anybody can put it on themselves
and because Joaquin is partially putting
on some of the makeup himself in the
movie you know we have to make sure that
you know it looks authentic and organic
and because of when working very complex
process of preparing for the character
it was actually quite helpful because he
wasn't really like he couldn't really
sit that still and he was always like on
the go and he's not the kind of person
that likes to be touched that much kind
of made it easier for me to not spend
too much time with him and not get it
too perfect in fact you know I had to go
really fast the whole hair and makeup
kay who was the hair designer she
applied the wig while I was doing the
makeup and all in all it took us no more
between like you know 25 minutes to get
it all done it actually works pretty
well surprisingly right I mean it's
really it was fascinating an incredible
experience so yeah so that's how you
know we kind of worked bombshell
if you worked on the hair design of the
film hair bomb shirt is the story ever
kind of the me to movement within Fox
News and again I suppose I'm the same
when we talk about character and not
wanting that with Rocketman I suppose
that you might not want to play into the
character of what a fox news woman looks
like and kind of play into that you know
the preconceptions that people have and
kind of the preconceptions that the
films trying to fight it the same point
so how did you work and kind of still
having the Fox look without it by
playing into kind of all of our
preconceptions and what that might be
yeah it's a funny thing you know because
our attention went to not demeaning
these women and making sure that we get
you know we we let them have the
validity of telling their story you know
and and and I say demeaning them by way
of Roger Ailes had created and curated a
look that was you know slowly over time
he wasn't just a leg man
it was about you know more hair more
blonde and
that's a Fox News facts like 98 percent
of the women at Fox or blondes that are
on camera I mean that's pretty crazy you
go down the rabbit hole of looking at
blondes in your life it was a particular
kind of blonde I mean it's a
head-turning
a head-turning thing you know light
causes the eye to turn right and the
blonde turns ahead and roger ailes knew
this and really just curated this look
and and that's what was so kind of crazy
and when we did that transformation of
Kayla's character is that when we did
the Fox makeover I mean it was obnoxious
it's it's three layers of lashes it's so
much makeup I mean and then I used
West's and her wig and her wig was just
a nice you know noir you know normal
weight to a girl's hair and then
normally if someone wants to add some
wesen to your hair to give a little bit
of wah-wah it's like you know baby you
got six tops right but there was twenty
four in her head it was insane and you
know she could barely walk in the dress
and it was like but this was not like
we're not making fun like this was a
very typical thing and what was so
amazing is when I went down the rabbit
hole of looking at Fox and the women
that were being portrayed and the women
that are real from Fox it was it was an
amazing to me like like subculture that
is not a subculture at all and we in
fact take it for granted that that would
be like oh that's not a big deal but
when you strip it down and you see all
the things and the overtly sexualized
Barbie doll is it becomes a caricature
that you try and and ease up and because
we shot it like cinema verite it had a
sense of reality to it you know the
camera moves a lot and and we let things
be fuzzy and a little broken in that you
know and you see Megan with no makeup on
or gretchen carlson with no makeup and
you know that with prosthetic pieces on
I mean
it's pretty cool I mean nose to nose
you're not seeing anything that's pretty
amazing event if we're moving to the
other extreme of prosthetics then with
19:17 let's start kind of in the idea of
this the single tape nature of the film
and how that affects the way you work
and kind of you know with creating
prosthetics you know I'm sure that that
had brought a new range of challenges or
perhaps you can never work with before
from the very beginning talking to some
it was it was the one shot and we were
planning it like three months before we
started to shoot so we were all in on it
we were all talking about how everything
needed to be designed and figured out
and quite quickly we started to get a
sense of that shot and how things were
laid into the shot and the periphery of
everything as the characters are moving
there was no edits cutaways you know so
everything had to be dressed into this
shot to a specific place almost so the
camera catches it at the right moment we
had to have the freedom for salmon Roger
to change on the day if we needed to so
everything was built as so high detail
as possible everything we like all the
heads for example or hair punch rather
than wigs because I wanted to be able to
offer as much much as much flexibility
in the scene that's possible for Sam you
know we could the bodies were all
articulated everything was prepared in a
way that we could change they could they
could be on set that actors could feel
the moment differently Roger might want
to move the camera differently so
everything was prepared to be changeable
which I mean I think it felt like
theatre to me the way we saw shot it in
sequence more or less and it just you
could feel it on sets and I think that I
realized what early on was important to
the way we built a music it had to be to
your eye wasn't a trick but you know we
didn't the camera we've run there there
was no back of the head or there was no
make up there or jeongmi and everything
had to be fully realized onset to it to
a level where you just believe it right
there and then and that allowed the
actors and everyone to sort of feel it
and move
the scene and bring that reality out of
of what was happening I mean we were
dealing with with real history and and
the whole story was pieced together from
stuff real stories and Diaries and some
stories from sons Sam's grandfather so
we had to be sensitive to that level of
detail as well so if we were making
corpses bodies injuries they couldn't be
overly graphic or it's just too much
because it would take you out of the
story you know it had to be real enough
for you to believe it's there that you
have a decaying horse or body or an
injury but it hadn't it couldn't shock
you and make you take you out of that
journey that you were focused on with
wisdom with Scofield all the kids now
I'm sure will got lots of questions
there are a couple of roving mics if you
can wait for a microphone or a film that
had inspired you and that ubicool is the
moment you knew this was what you wanted
to do as a career the reason why I
wanted to go into makeup was when I was
14 I saw the Exorcist and I was like
what is this oh my how did they do that
that was my first like makeup wow this
is amazing
I want to do that
with Universal Studios when I was in
fourth grade and I saw them change
someone into Abe Lincoln and I became
like obsessed with that and then you
know you go you life goes on and then I
circled background yeah
yeah so fourth grade Abe Lincoln books
ebooks that it takes Facebook and Tom
Savini and I just got really fascinated
and the each page I turned I was like on
my cart right and seeing behind the
scenes and the malls and the sculpting I
just didn't knew I didn't know that
world existed so I just got captivated
by behind the scenes that end up I love
movies anyway but fell in love further
with movies and just characters and
monsters and just the creation of
makeups and how you can turn someone or
something into something that didn't
exist before and bring it to life I just
sort of fell into that world and just
loved it and what the Rick Baker did he
was about 1981 need to service something
and I remember just being really
inspired and awed by it and thinking my
god somebody can do this as a career and
then living so I think from that point I
mean I was probably about so seven or
eight years old and haven't seen the
film itself but seen the
behind-the-scenes making-of so I think
from that point I decided I wanted to be
a bit of a monster maker and as Tristan
is saying I think he was sort of mid 80s
I was picking up books by him and Tom
Savini and dick Smith and just try and
try and get home gluing bits of rubber
and plaster and latex and stuff all over
my face and and then it I think it's
just steamrolled from there and he's
sort of following the work of Rick Baker
dick Smith and greats really never done
anything else and I came to London
College of Fashion I got in and just
being in the right place at the right
time
I was just inspired by Hollywood itself
actually from about the age of four I
was I was in dancing and everything and
I just used to be fascinated when all
the makeup came out and we used to have
people coming around to make us up for
our little dance numbers and I just
thought I can't do that and that's how
it started my sister is here so I wanted
to say when I was 10 years old I used to
torture my sister putting the kiss
makeup because it was obsessed with that
makeup I used to put it on her all the
time she was 6 I was 10 and every
weekend come on let's do this Thank You
Jesse I want to think out of time so I
want to thank you all so much for coming
congratulations on your world deserved
nominations I want to thank the Lancome
for supporting this session thank you
[Music]
[Music]